welcome to today's live demo in episode
five of cloud AIT Cloud Essentials we're
going to be diving deep into using the
platform to teach data courses in
workshops um if this is your first time
watching my name is Alex Chisum and I
work on the posit Cloud here posit Cloud
team here at posit I'm also really
excited um to have a co-speaker for the
first time who knows a lot about the
intersection of R and data science and
education really as much as anyone M
would you like to introduce yourself
yeah thanks for having me today um so my
name is minina chitin arandel I'm a
developer educator at pit in the open
source team uh but I'm also a faculty
member at Duke University and I have
been using posit Cloud for quite a few
years now at this point um at times as
part of my oncampus teaching um and at
times um for teaching workshops that are
either short-term or long-term workshops
outside up here so I'm happy to share my
experiences yeah that's great we're very
glad to have you here with us today um
and before we get into the benefits of
of teaching with posit Cloud I just
wanted to say if you have any questions
along the way please drop them into the
chat box we will get to them in real
time if we come across them or we have
time at the end to Circle back um after
the demo we're going to be to be running
um so what I'd like to start with
actually is before we as instructors
were lucky enough to have Cloud
environments uh to to teach like what
life was like and I want to take you
back to a troubling time in 2016 where I
tried and failed for the first time to
get students in like a data literacy
type course up and running uh with
coding and everybody was really really
exciting and excited about the
opportunity so it was kind of
disappointing the first time where we
had everybody pull up their desktop
idees and we spent the entire first
class like troubleshooting individual uh
pains that that people were going
through trying to get up and running
right so like I couldn't get the Right
Packages installed I couldn't find you
know the files that you're asking me to
connect to
what even is a working directory I'm on
a different operating system like all of
these questions uh would come up and it
just it became very difficult to have a
starting point for all the students to
start at the same place um I'm curious M
from your perspective like do you have
like one or multiple moments of painful
teaching experiences from this type of
uh of
pain yeah I do I um you know I bet the
pain is felt differently from the
student side but as an instructor I can
sort of pinpoint two things one is um
when I would try to teach with um IDE
sort of like on installed individually
on student machines one thing I realized
is that I am not great at
troubleshooting on an operating system
different than my own so I've been a Mac
User for quite some time now uh as I've
been learning to use our andr studio so
I'm pretty familiar with when you
install things where they go and how to
troubleshoot them um and I have always
felt awful when a student comes up to me
with a Windows machine and what I tell
them is I don't know how to help you oh
but I can help your friend who has an
operating system uh similar to mine or
sometimes some students will have their
operating systems um in a different
natural language than English or a
language I speak and that usually feels
really bad too and I can't help them
another thing though is that for my
classroom teaching I have been using
Some Cloud version of our studio I want
to say forever um back in the day um our
studio the company would actually uh you
know allow a few instructors to sort of
run a hosted version of uh what was then
our
studio server I suppose um and I would
use that but something I had not
realized is that when you distribute a
data file to students and you're
teaching in a computer lab app so the
machines are not the students and not
your own but the universities students
might have no idea where the downloaded
files go so even if you you know think
that you are 100% prepared to teach
you've even sort of set up your
Computing environment and you think
things are ready to go you go to the
computer lab and the first thing you're
faced with is where are the files are
downloaded and I remember spending about
20 minutes trying to get started with a
class thinking this is not where I
thought we would choke so these things
do happen and it seems like it's very
difficult to be prepared to teach in an
environment different than one that you
can
access yeah that that's completely
completely fair and accurate I think
that's where posit cloud has made
teaching a lot easier for for a lot of
people um in my role here I've worked
with a lot of U individual instructors
that are kind of running their own their
own course within a university also with
with um entire departments that have
multiple instructors that are coming
aboard and people that are just running
running workshops but this ability to
get students up running with the same
environment the same files from the
get-go really has just saved a lot of
time on the on the instructor side um
but as you mentioned from a student side
as well it doesn't lead to these these
burdens um um right away which can be
frustrating when you're just learning
out which takes away some of that
excitement um so we feel that you know
by by finding a way to build a course or
build a workshop around posit Cloud
you're not only saving the time and
effort of getting people in that this
unified en environment but are able to
bring people into this space where the
system is going to scale with you and if
you have more students or if you have
more instructors they can kind of work
into that flow as
well and when we're thinking about like
you know how do you go about and just
deliver any kind of educational course
you know broadly speaking um you know it
likely F follows something like like
this right you're trying to set up with
some kind of learning objectives you
know what do you what do you hope to
impart to students what do you want the
output outcomes to be why do you believe
that they're important uh from that
you're putting together course material
what's going to put them on the best
path path to acquire uh to achieve these
learning objectives getting into uh
content distribution being able to take
a project or take some code or just take
a concept um and put it in front of
people at the right time and then
finally the ability to support um and
assess along the way so you know was it
effective uh where were the pain points
you know what individual issues came up
that needed to have um to be looked at a
little bit more closely so I'm curious M
like does does this align with like your
mental model as you're preparing courses
um specifically data courses which might
be a little bit different than than
teaching something that doesn't have a
technical or a coding based uh
perspective um it aligns very well with
the instructor I aspire to be um but I
think that sometimes things go a little
bit differently where I find myself sort
of circling more than once um through
this which is that you know creating
course materials that seems like the
type of thing you should be doing at the
beginning of the semester for example
like however uh for me it's usually
something that I'm doing throughout the
semester to be perfectly honest at times
it's because I just don't have
everything ready at the beginning but
also because sometimes you know I read
about a cool feature in a new released
version of a package or something new
with quto and what I want to do is I
want to be able to show in class the
next day this new thing I've learned
about so that might mean that now I want
um you know the most recent version of a
package to be installed on the
environment where my students are going
to be doing the Computing and to be able
to have access to do that myself as
opposed to going through it has always
been really nice and also Distributing
content as well um you know I don't
necessarily have every single homework
assignment every single inclass exercise
prepared and ready to go to be sort of
like distributed at once to students so
usually these things unravel uh
throughout the semester I also find that
students find it overwhelming to be
delivered everything at once and it
allows me to Pace things a little bit
better based on how class went so that
flexibility of making things visible to
students at a particular rate is another
thing that I really um
like yeah it I'm curious what courses
are you typically teaching we we talk
with a lot of people that are teaching
psychology or economics or statistics or
getting into data science where's your
focus um so I am a faculty in the
statistics Department um my primary
focus for teaching is introductory
education so that's introductory
statistics or introduction to data
science the courses I've taught most
regularly most recently have been
introduction to data science using the
data science in a box curriculum but I
also teach data visualization courses
both at the introductory and advanced
level as well I teach a few other things
here and there too but these have been
sort of like the ones uh that I teach
most regularly and usually quite large
classes what is quite large in your from
your point of view um well next semester
it'll be almost 300 students so that's
large for my University yeah yeah yeah
fantastic yeah digging in a little bit
to these themes a little bit more um so
starting out with the learning
objectives you know one of the courses
that I taught years ago was just this
data literacy type course data as a
second language so I knew I had three
units right I wanted people to
understand what data is I wanted them to
be able to manipulate it in more
sophisticated ways then I also wanted
them to be able to go out and
communicate uh to other people so when
thinking through once I had that that
bad experience trying to do things you
know with everybody on their own on
their own laptops uh I moved into you
know what could posit Cloud kind of like
deliver and how could I take some of
this content and put it into some of the
functions and features on posit Cloud um
so the first part was you know like what
can I teach within our studio IDE later
posit cloud is added jupyter notebook uh
which is still in a beta but for those
instructors who do want to have some
some native python uh coding material
they can do it through that and then
where am I going to get my data examples
how are they going to to be brought into
the system are we going to go out and
just you know import CSV files uh more
recently posit Cloud added data
connections uh this year which makes it
easier to connect to databases which
from what I understand are not often
taught in a lot of data courses
especially at the underground gr
language level um in terms of just
connecting and being able to start doing
manipulation but we found some really
great public databases um that are out
there that allow you like to to put in a
postrest connection uh make that
connection and start performing analysis
on it which is which is great um M are
you are you typically working with flat
files at this point point are you using
data files from within packages what is
your go-to Source um mostly flat files
we start with data files from packages
so my um my teaching style is that the
first thing we teach is data
visualization so we sort of start by
visualizing data that is
already not necessarily I would say
cleaned up but in a data frame format
let's say so already in R um the
variable types are what you expect them
to be like factors or and stuff like
that so that's why we start with um data
sets and packages and then we take a
step back and import data primarily from
um from Flat files so Excel or CSV files
or Google Sheets is another one that we
tend to import data from um I don't
teach databases much um but another
thing we do teach is web scraping so
then in that case the data is coming
from an unstructured source and then uh
using Code getting structured into a
data frame
yeah yeah great and then bringing this
into what the course would look like in
posit Cloud posit Cloud I think is
powerful from an educational point of
view because it's based around this
notion of a space so you you create
account as we're going to see in a demo
in a few minutes you're able to create
this dedicated space you can use it for
whatever you want you can bring in
specific people um so when thinking
through it from the point of view of
bringing in course materials you you can
make a space you can bring in new
projects you can create our Studio
Projects or Jupiter projects you can now
publish some outputs um as well to the
space if you have quto let's say um
maybe summarizing the semester's content
um and then once you do this you're able
to manage all the content that that you
have within this given contained
environment so once you have it there
you want to go out and and be able to
put it in the hands of students so there
are a couple ways we'll look at where
you can invite um students to your space
directly controlling what they are able
and not able to do and then what they
are able and not able to see at
different moments so MIA mentioned
earlier like not overwhelming students
in throwing up every single thing from
the semester we have some um features on
positive Cloud that can make that easier
as
well and then at the end of all this
like once you have students that are in
the space they will able to access your
content and go along and learn kind of
in real time with you uh your ability as
an instructor to go into a student's
project be able to run the code maybe
see what is going wrong potentially fix
issues or work collaboratively um make
make comments and then you know at the
end of all this right we were talking
about you know how do we assess and
evaluate work um and I know that you
know we don't have actually built-in
functionality right now on posit Cloud
to really support the the grading aspect
of things so I'm curious me in all these
courses that you've taught over the
years like what is your what is your
process for evaluating um you know
learning outcomes from from this type of
material so usually it it really depends
on on um the the course that I'm
teaching in my intro stat courses um
what we the evaluation actually in any
of the courses I teach the evaluation
itself happens outside of posit Cloud so
students submited using whatever course
management system we're using so in my
introductory statistics course that is
happening on um grade scope for example
so they uh render their quto document to
a PDF file that they then export out of
that posit Cloud project and then they
um upload it to grade scope and that's
where the grading is happening basically
and feedback is being given there as
well uh with my intro data science
courses uh there is also a git and
GitHub component to the course so in
that case everything is submitted as a
GitHub
repository and the evaluation um
depending on the course is either done
there or on grade scope as well the way
we've been like for courses where I
teach teach posit Cloud the way it has
come into play has been more on the sort
of the support side the going to a like
not the assessment side but the support
side being able to sort of go in and U
diagnose for the students what the issue
might be and I will say that that's
usually not like a first thing I uh
offer to the students you know if we're
even if we're physically together in
office hours um but also if we're not
and we're talking on like a course uh
discussion forum or something I try to
get them to articulate what the issue is
uh but sometimes it turns out that we're
not getting anywhere with that and the
student is getting more frustrated
because they sort of don't have the
right terms and I can't see what they're
doing and um maybe they're not sharing
like a full screenshot with me of what's
happening so being able to just peek in
uh not necessarily always to fix the
issues but to understand what the issue
is and then leave this space and then
articulate to them here is what you
might want to look into um it's really
really
nice yeah that's great advice uh what
I'd like to do now before we get into a
live demo um is just talk a little bit
about the two ways that you might be
able to set up um instructor style
accounts on posa cloud um if you are
like an individual instructor or you are
running workshops you know you can
create an individual account you can go
up and if you have five different
courses you can make five different
spaces or you can use one space and
reuse it for different groups and
cohorts of students that are coming
through if you are part of a wider group
within your your institution or your
University um we have organizational
accounts where there can be sort of
central management of you know the
instructors that you would like to be to
Part of That So this means like
centralized billing and also the ability
to sort of Monitor and see you know
who's doing what in which uh which space
so what I would like to do now is hop
over to posa Cloud so I'm going to
switch into the browser here here and
I'm going to go ahead and log in and
we'll start just by looking at the
individual um approach to doing this and
what I always encourage like if you're
if you're new on this call um and you
haven't been in posit Cloud yet uh there
are free accounts that are available and
it's the best way to sort of experience
and feel what posit cloud is like um
because we don't gate a lot of this
functionality by different tiers of of
service like if you if you were to have
a paid plan eventually you would have
like more compute hours and you'd have
more compute power um but all the things
all the building blocks um such as
spaces and projects are going to be
there on a free account as well so let
me go ahead and log in now and the first
time that you get into posit Cloud
you're going to get to a relatively
plain page that is known as your
workspace and here you could you could
start building projects and you could
see you know the specific project that
you might be working on but what you
can't do in this first space is invite
others to collaborate with you and of
course we're looking at education here
um so we want want to have students we
want to have a back and forth of our of
our content and for this we're going to
go to this notion of space so if I click
on the end and I scroll down I can
create a new space and maybe we call
this you know stat
250 uh most people won't have a drop
down here but if you have multiple
accounts you can access you could choose
one here I'm going to go to my individ
individual personal account and just
create this
space so we have a new course area you
can see that two new tabs popped up I
have both data which are these data
connections that I mentioned earlier so
if you do work into your curriculum some
ability to go out and touch a real
database you can set up the credentials
here so that students don't don't need
to be entering these themselves over and
over again um but more importantly we
have this member Tab and here's where
where we're going to be able to have a
couple of different ways to bring in
different people into our space to
engage with our
content and we'll do that in in a in a
few moments but first all start off with
like the core functionality right you
see this drop down new project if I
click on this I see four options I can
either create a project from a template
and if I were to do this you're going to
see a few things first you're going to
see that we don't have a template
defined specifically for our new space
yet we could do that and we'll do that
in in a few moments time or you could
create um a new project from a template
that that really posit has put together
for you so for instance um we have data
analysis in r with the tidyverse if you
were to go into that you'd be able to
see uh a markdown document that talks
through different functionality within
the Tidy verse for basic exploratory
analysis and all the packages all the
data that you would need for those
examples would already be included in
there but the most common thing I think
teachers do uh they go through and they
create a new R Studio
project and maybe this will be called
you know week one Eda you know depending
on what we're teaching um it's going to
take about 15 to 20 seconds to go ahead
and spin up a new instance specifically
for your project and then once you're in
it I would say 90 95% of what you'd
expect on our studio you know ID on your
desktop you'd be able to to achieve and
accomplish here as well um so you can go
ahead and you know upload files from
your local environment you can make
those database connections um either
through the ones that we defined earlier
through posit cloud or a new one through
through other database drivers that that
happen to be available
we could build in markdown files code
again we could bring in data to support
all of this and essentially building up
what you want in week one for your
students to be able to to engage
with I also won't publish anything here
but I'll show you the functionality we
have as well so maybe you're working
with a shiny
app what we can
do is build up this shiny app and we'll
just look at the the base one that comes
included
we're going to have to go out and get
all the packages first and that's what
it's downloading right
[Music]
now and then once that is
complete I'm going to go ahead and call
this
test going to make sure that when we run
this app we're going to do it in our
window so we can see it within the
pane so we can see right away our
interactive shiny application and
because we're all part of this same
unified experience on posit Cloud if I
wanted to publish this to my space for
other students to see uh you could do
that so again we're just going to go
ahead and install the required packages
to make this publication um published to
posit cloud and you can see by default
where it's asking you to go um is to the
space that we're putting it in so we
won't do that now but if we did and we
go back to our content list we would see
both the project that we just created
the week one Eda and we would see the
project now at the moment we're missing
two key components to to teaching a
course right we're missing students to
look at things um and we're also missing
the ability for students who might be
here to see uh what you've worked on so
this first our studio project if you
wanted to put that in the hands of
students in your space you can see that
it's marked
private we're going to go into settings
and we're going to go to access we're
going to change that private to space
member
so that's the first thing that you would
do uh to put the content in front of of
students that are in the space and then
we have two options here that are that
can be very relevant I think when
teaching a course uh the first is making
this project an
assignment and if I were to click on
this you can see that there is an
assignment button that comes uh with
that week one Eda and now when a student
were to join the space they would come
in and it would it would change to for
them they would see start so they know
that there's an action on it they would
click Start it would make a copy of the
project specifically for them that then
they could interact with um without
risking you know what you put together
in your first one it's a safe
environment that they can go back and
they can create it again and again and
again if they wanted to we also the
ability now with a new feature called
templates to turn this into a specific
template for this space so if I click on
template it's going to take away the
assignment functionality I can make this
template something that we can get from
that initial list of start a new project
with templates I can also make it the
default for every single R studio uh
project that comes from this
space let's just go ahead and and save
it as template just to show you where
this would now pop up it becomes a
template within your space and any
student that came because it's available
for all space members when you click on
new project from template you can see
Week 1 Eda so there are a couple of
different ways you can do things now now
that we have template functionality as
well um we'll look at in a few moments
another example of using templates maybe
to like surface like all the data sets
you want to be able to share out um
throughout a semester and if a student
wants to create a new project from those
core data sets they could again come
back and back to this this template mini
I'm curious when you're setting up
courses uh on posit Cloud are you
typically using assignments or templates
or or nothing at all both so I
definitely use a template um
particularly because there's a you know
I always use the Tidy verse packages and
I like being able I teach with Library
tidy verse so I want to make sure that
we have all of the Tidy verse packages
installed even if for a given lesson we
may not be using all of them and so
that's one of the things I put in my
template for sure and also um you know
rendering a quto document with r code in
there requires a Knitter to be installed
and stuff so I make sure that all of
that is installed in the template so
that's the first thing I set and every
once in a while throughout the semester
I'll update the template too so that
going forward like we use the new
packages U but usually that stays for
the semester and then for each day that
I teach so the semester I'm teaching an
introductory statistics course where
we're using posit cloud and um every
single day we have an application
exercise in the class so that's like a
live coding thing so I have stubs of
code that I share with the student in a
quto document and then we sort of
improve upon them uh during the in-class
exercises those those are set as
assignments and I make them visible sort
of shortly before class um and then
their homework assignments and stuff are
also distributed as assignments what I
like is that it nicely contains them for
the students so in my opinion it's sort
of a almost an improvement above working
with the ID for Learners because the
idea of switching between projects in
the local ID is I think something that
comes with experience versus in posit
Cloud to switch between like different
sets of documents you have to switch the
project so I feel like it teaches you to
think about projects um earlier than you
might otherwise which is I think a
benefit yeah yeah I think you're right
uh let me jump now from the the space we
just built into one that looks a little
bit more build in um and we don't have
time obviously during a quick demo to
put this together but I'm going to go
into spring 2022 and here I've got a
course um it's filled out you can see
that you know we've got a bunch of files
here a lot of them are repeating in
names uh the reason for that is that
these are coming from students who have
made copies of these assignments um but
you can see right away we've got more
going on in this space it maybe even a
little bit overwhelming at first so if
you were the professor and you you came
in maybe mid semester and you saw all of
your students interactions with a bunch
of different files we have ways to
filter this down as well so if you click
on your content now you see essentially
what you have made and what you have
released to the group so we have two
assignments you can see manipulating
data which is available for all space
members understanding data available for
all space members and then we have a
third one communicating data which is
still private so right now a student
which we'll see in a few moments who
comes into the space wouldn't see this
because it's not yet available um for
them and we have the two assignments as
I mentioned we also have this template
and the template is just an our studio
project that has a bunch of different
data sets that if a student ever wanted
to build a project on with those
libraries that that M mentioned and with
a bunch of of data sets that they can
test it out they could because we've
made it a template go to the new project
from template and see sample data sets
and again create that that project with
all those assets
pre-inclusion a few of the content items
were matched back to individual students
and you can see here right now in our
course we have we have me and then we
have student a b and c each of them are
given this contributor level uh of
permissions and if you click on initial
role here on the far right you can see
who can do what but typically if you are
the the instructor you're going to be
the admin on the account and if if you
have students that are joining you want
them to be contributors they're going to
be able to engage with the material
you've put up there but they're also
going to be able to create their own
projects when they want to and play
around um again in a safe way that isn't
going to break anything there are also
two ways to bring members to your space
um so if I click on ad member uh the
first thing that's going to come from
this uh especially if I click on
invitation required and I click add
member I'm going to have an email
address so I could put in a new
individual's email address um I could
tell them specific information um in the
copy of the email for them to come join
the space they would receive it an email
they would click the link they would
come deposit Cloud if they already have
an account they could simply just go
ahead and accept it if they don't
they'll be required to sign up for for a
free uh version and then they can come
in on most education plans when you
start having a lot of people in your
course uh you might want to just go
ahead and use a sharing link so here we
have an anonymous link that I can copy
and now on my clipboard I've got this
link I can give it to to students in a
chat or or via a generic email people
could follow this and then come into to
the space and what I'd like to do now is
take that link and show you what it
looks like from a students's perspective
who received this invitation so I need
to switch my screen
here and I'm going to bring it now to my
other
window okay I think you you can see it
so here we are on posit Cloud on a
student uh laptop let's imagine I'm
going to paste in the invitation to join
that space I do already have an account
on this system so I'm going to go ahead
and log
in and now gustoff is going to be able
to get an invitation to this space are
you willing to join if the answer is yes
you come in the first thing you see is
some about text that the instructor uh
was able to put in the the space
specifically and then next time they log
in they won't go there they'll go
straight to this content area and we can
see a few things uh we can see that I've
got four pieces of
content and I've already joined this
space under this account which is why
this one is saying continue but if you
look at manipulating data like this is
something that this student has not yet
started and when they click on
this we can see that a project does open
up it's called manipulating data it's
going to have the initial code in that
we want the student to to experience and
play with it will also have all the
packages and data sets um that were able
to be set up initially but what this
does is it doesn't take your project the
instructor project that you put together
it saves it as their as their own so we
can see here now we've got manipulating
data it is from that student D it is
currently private so only they can see
it within their space only they can see
as well as the admin uh instructor can
see this content list and we can see
that they can even filter down the
information a little bit better to see
what's going on in unit one and maybe
what's going on in unit
two now we talked on the other screen
about that template so imagine the
student comes into the space and they
don't have this thing about data sets
you could say well go create a project
from a template and you can you'll be
able to find uh the different templates
that are made available within the
space
so if I switch back one last time to the
instructor
View and go refresh my member
[Music]
tab I can now see that I have this this
new person this student D who is who has
joined the space um so I've got four
students they're all able to engage with
the content that I make available for
them the final thing that I'll show is
the usage so not only do are we able to
bring people into our space engage with
our content we're also able to keep a
pretty good look at you know who's doing
what and who's being active down to the
content level so you can see this is
showing us that in this month the
calendar month there have been four
hours of compute associated with
projects and outputs in the space there
are eight unique pieces of content and
they're four active members if I scroll
down we're going to see that we have the
instructor and we have students a
through C already have some compute time
associated with it student D just joined
and at the moment they don't have um any
compute associated with them but if you
were to click on student B let's say we
can see these 1.14 hours uh came from
two different projects understanding and
manipulating data so we have some usage
statistics in here as
well so that primarily is how you can
bring your content into a space engage
students and get them to to experience
it I've seen a few questions come in um
along the way for this specifically you
know maybe now let's see if some of
these are good to answer at the
moment so bu's asking is there a way to
share a project with someone who is not
a member of my course
workspace and there there are two
answers to this one if you're talking
about a course space the answer is no
you need to be able to invite someone in
there as a member give them the proper
visibility to see them that in the
personal workspace there is actually a
way to do this you can make that first
uh personal workspace that we looked at
when we logged in if you were to put
something there you can say share with
other Cloud users and then if someone
else has a posit cloud account they can
be able to access that that project we
can drop let me drop into the uh channel
here the guide and if you look at the
differences in sharing between that
personal space and let's see if I can
find the
ox actually don't see where I can drop
in a direct reply here um but I'll I'll
share it on on the YouTube channel
through uh through our our our friend
Hannah um then we'll be able to to tell
where you can do these specific
things so
lastly we've gone through the live demo
we talked about how we can build a a
specific data course
we knew from the beginning that this has
sort of taken away some of the pain
points both on the instructor side and
the student
side we have a lot of uptick in the
education uh Community 17 of the top
Global uh universities are either using
posit Cloud as an institution or with
individual instructors we've had
thousands of instructors and workshop
leaders go through using posit Cloud for
these these courses and workshops and
hundreds of thousands of students um
have started their their data science
learning path on the
tool it's also quite um flexible in
terms of how you can get involved um at
the moment instructors are $15 a month
and there are a variety of ways that you
can go ahead and sign up for accounts if
you're able to use credit cards we have
very very flexible monthly subscriptions
where you can add students remove
students if you're on an organizational
account you can go ahead and add
additional instructors as well
um if you're working with very large
cohorts uh and maybe a purchase order
makes more sense for you we're flexible
there as well um and can talk through
your needs on a case-by Case
basis in each one you know to set up
ways to accommodate your student costs
there there three primary um approaches
either you can pay a $5 per student
monthly fee um for the for the student
you can have each student pay it for
themselves or you can set up an account
uh again through stripe through a credit
card on the platform uh that only will
go back to the the usage within your
space so you would pay $15 for your
instructor fee and then anything above
that would just be upon based upon the
compute hours used by students in your
space so again I encourage you to to go
to pit. Cloud uh create a free account
play around with some of the
functionality that we looked looked at
today um and and really I I think if you
haven't tried teaching you know through
a cloud-based system yet
uh you're in for a real treat um both
from the preparation it takes to get all
of your content in one place and the
ability to bring on students in a pretty
seamless way um thank you very much for
for attending this m thank you so much
for for joining us and giving your your
incredible and very practiced um
opinions on using POS Cloud for this
type of education uh at this point I'd
like to invite back on Hannah uh who's
on our side and is going to help with
the Q&A that's come on the board as
we've been going through for the
presentation hey thank you thanks Alex
thanks M um yeah like Alex said I'm
Hannah I'm on the marketing team here at
pit so I'm just going to moderate some
of the questions that have been coming
in today and just a reminder if you
still have questions we've got a chunk
of time here at the end to answer them
so feel free to keep on submitting
questions and we'll just run through
them as we receive them um but the first
question that I would like to ask you
both is from San J and he asked if you
were ask that's the top reason for what
you like about posit Cloud what would be
your
response I think M should answer this
one um so I think I have the top reason
I would say is being able to peek into
student project so easily um I think
that feels like a superpower even when
you're not with them you can do this um
this was incredibly helpful when we were
teaching fully virtually a couple of
years ago but I still find it very
useful even though teaching is happening
in person and but I have to add that
second reason which is the fact that
everything is like a contained project
so students don't have to worry about
sort of file paths and where they put
their files you set up the file
structure for them and they start
Computing in there which I find to be
very helpful for new Learners um as
opposed to sort of bogging down with
bogging them down with those details as
well on day one
class yeah the only thing I would add is
the flexibility of spinning up new
courses of adding and removing students
like it makes it very easy to sort of
build that cohort that you want to see
the content that you're putting
together yeah that's super
helpful next question I'll go
to uh when I share with my students a
project all installed our packages are
available to them but that does not seem
to be the case with python packages is
that really the case or is there
something
else I think if you're using Jupiter
notebooks the best thing that you can do
is to set up through the templating
functionality that we looked at so for
sure using that templating functionality
you start a new jupyter notebook project
you bring in all the packages that that
you want to and then if you set that as
a template your students are going to be
able to access that project with all
those pre-install packages that are
there
awesome and then I think you answered
the next question so I'll skip that one
go to this one
is it possible to publish on posit Cloud
say an HTML document generated from a
Cordo notebook that can be shared
publicly and anyone with the link can
access it at this point no all sharing
on posit cloud has to go either to
somebody within your space or to another
person that has a posit cloud
account
okay next question from Ralph is if
students want to access their work after
a workshop
I conduct corporate training for other
companies what are the options besides
just keeping them as a student in
perpetuity Min how do you handle a sort
of content transfer during your
courses um so I think one of two things
uh some students uh can choose to
transfer
that project into their own work space
so they can move it um more often I also
have students who just export the
project out like locally so they make
sort of a local folder of all of their
work whether it's from a workshop or a
course um so that exporting and then
like keeping a copy of it locally is
another thing that I've
done and then the other thing is if
you're also teaching like if there is a
GitHub repository connected to the um to
the project or the space then so not
space I guess the project to the project
um the the text files and the data files
can be there as well that doesn't solve
um you know the the sort of the packages
side of things but at least it solves
the other
content
awesome let's go over to the question
from Jason Jason asked I have an account
for an academic researcher do I have to
create a new account for teaching or
kind of what would you suggest I think
it's going to depend on the level of
teaching that you're doing I know
there's some limits on that that that
academic researcher plan in terms of how
many people can come into your to your
space um I'd recommend looking either
reaching out to us that we can have a
conversation about what exactly it is
you're trying to accomplish or checking
out what those instructure plans look
like and see if that could also meet
your
needs I'm going to jump over to a slido
question that we got a bit earlier I
think someone asked maybe a little bit
more generally about just teaching data
courses they said do you have a favorite
piece of advice you've received related
to teaching data
courses um I'll try to take this so I
would say I think the best advice that
I've received has been
around trying to get a sense of like the
background of your students which is you
know in a way easy to do at the
University City level because they are
prerequisites associated with the course
and these are like strictly um enforced
generally so you kind of have a sense of
the background of your
students or the lack of a background of
your students in the content that you're
teaching but when I teach workshops um
that's not necessarily the case so
something where I where if possible
doing a short survey uh where you can
get a sense of what they know and what
they don't know ahead of time I find to
be really helpful and I'll be honest
that's not to say that then I tailor the
entire
Workshop based on the data that I get
from them because that's usually not
possible um people you know sign up for
a workshop knowing what the content is
go or having read what the content is
going to be but I think it does change
how I articulate certain things and how
much time I spend on certain details so
that would be one thing um and then the
other thing is
uh you know I think live coding is one
of the best things for teaching um data
uh courses of any kind whether that's
like a long-term course at the
University or a short workshop and with
live coding I find it really helpful to
be able to do the live coding in the
same environment that your students are
doing it because as a I think one of the
most frustrating things for Learners
tend to be no I ran the same code you
ran but I'm getting different results
it's never exactly different results but
maybe something looks slightly different
or they're getting an error because they
haven't installed a package that you
have installed or something like that so
just being able to sort of do the live
coding in the same environment um is
really important so I think one of the
sort of the best pieces of advice I
received was to do more and more live
coding and um anything that facil
facilitates that I find very
helpful yeah one thing that I heard was
don't try to teach too much like I first
started teaching right and like I was
given a textbook and they said this is
what you're teaching and I try to teach
every single thing in that chapter where
especially like at the intro level I
found like you want to get people's
appetite up for data you want them to be
excited enough to go on and learn bigger
and better things and cramming
everything down their throats in a
limited period of time wasn't wasn't
that helpful mean I also mentioned like
running a survey to understand them the
the other thing that that I would
recommend that I thought worked well was
making the data that they're initially
looking into especially for people that
don't really understand data at all data
that they generated because then they
really understand where it's coming from
and what it is and this can be as simple
as saying you know an anonymous survey
and then throwing up you know weight and
height and turning that into like a
correlation you know regression type
analysis because people can see their
data turning into something meaningful
right away and I found that was always
useful that's awesome thanks for sharing
so I'll go on to the next question that
we received and this one's from Nikki
she asked what suggestions do you have
for seamlessly utilizing posit cloud and
canvas LMS in a
course yeah right now we don't have any
formal Integrations I do know some uh
universities are experimenting with ways
of people exporting things from work on
posit cloud and then uploading those
into canvas for for sub subsequent
grading I don't think we've got a great
use case they're built in right now mean
have you attempted anything or is are
these separate
environments uh separate environments so
we also use um cams but my students will
export their um sort of PDFs of the
assignments that they're working on and
then we'll upload them to grade scope
basically but it's they're doing the
exporting and uploading we don't have a
sort of a connection between the
two I think we made it through all the
questions we've received so far um so if
you all have any more questions feel
free to drop them in and we'll wait a
minute or so more uh to hang on the line
and answer them one thing I would share
is that there's a library of past posit
Cloud essential events that you can view
at any time along with the recording of
this event if you'd like to go back to
certain sections and that'll be on our
YouTube channel and I'll share that Link
in the chat with you
all great thank you thank you Hannah and
M really thank you so much for joining
us today I know you have another course
to go teach in just a few minutes time
so we really appreciate your your time
and your perspectives thanks for having
me yes so I don't see any more questions
coming in so I think we've answered them
all but thank you both so much for
joining today answering questions um
going through this I think it was super
helpful so thank you all thank you all
for joining and submitting your
questions and uh we'll see you next time
all right thanks a lot